(audience cheers and applauds)
- Welcome back, everybody!
Throughout the hour,
we've explored how music
has shaped the pursuit of
equality across this country.
Our next guests are all
about promoting harmony
with their multi-genre acapella vocals.
Now performing "I Wish I Knew
How It Would Feel To Be Free,"
give it up for King's Return.
(audience cheers and applauds)
(singers harmonizing)
♪ I wish I knew how it
would feel to be free ♪
♪ I wish I could break all
the chains holding me ♪
♪ Oh, I wish I could say all
the things that I should say ♪
♪ Say 'em loud, say 'em loud ♪
♪ Say 'em clear, say 'em clear ♪
♪ For the whole round world to hear ♪
♪ I wish I could share
all the love in my heart ♪
♪ Remove all the bars that keep us apart ♪
♪ How I wish you could know
what it means to be me ♪
♪ Then you'd see and agree
how it feels to be free ♪
♪ You'd see, you'd see and
agree how it feels to be free ♪
♪ I wish I could give
all I'm longin' to give ♪
♪ Oh, I wish I could live
like I'm longin' to live ♪
♪ Oh, I wish I could do all
the things that I can do ♪
♪ Though I'm way, though I'm way ♪
♪ Overdue, overdue ♪
♪ I'd be starting anew ♪
♪ I wish I could be
like a bird in the sky ♪
♪ The sky ♪
♪ How sweet, how sweet it would
be if I found I could fly ♪
♪ I'd soar to the sun and
look down at the sea ♪
♪ And I'd sing 'cause I'd
know how it feels to be free ♪
♪ You'd see, you'd see and
agree how it feels to be free ♪
♪ You'd see and agree
how it feels to be free ♪
♪ You'd see, you'd see and
agree how it feels to be free ♪
♪ You'd see and agree
how it feels to be free ♪
♪ Then you'd see and agree
♪ I'd sing because I'd know
what it feels like to be free ♪
♪ Then you'd see, you'd see ♪
♪ 'Cause I know just how
it feels to be free ♪
(audience cheers and applauds)
- All right, once more
put your hands together
for King's Return, everybody!
Their latest album is
called "We Four Kings."
Pick it up wherever you get your music.
We'll be right back.